Speaker 1: I have to mention. That in his
latest tirade in which he goes full conspiracy,
Donald Trump now doesn't even look orange. It's
like burnt Sienna for those who used to watch Bob
Ross, I can only describe this as the color of
a sunset very late in the evening. I don't know
why Trump is doing this to himself, but he is
now a bizarre color and he is raising the deep
state In his latest full conspiracy rant, Trump
is now announcing if indeed he becomes the next
president of the United States, he will create a
truth commission. This now does sound like 1984.
You know, for for so long now, I've been
saying everybody says this is Orwellian,
It's really Huxley. And this is really more
out of Brave New World than it is out of 1984.
The Truth commission Trump wants is more
Orwellian. Here's Trump's latest promise.
I don't know, folks. This is scary stuff.
Speaker 3: But to expose the hoaxes and abuses
of power that have been tearing our country apart.
Oh, we will establish a Truth and Reconciliation
Commission to declassify and publish all
documents on deep stage spying, censorship
and corruption. And there are plenty of them.
Right? Fifth, we will launch a major crackdown
on government leakers who collude with the fake
news to deliberately weave false narratives.
Speaker 1: Now understand that's a crackdown on
whistleblowers. Trump calls them false leakers.
But in many of these cases, we're talking
about whistleblowers. And Trump clearly
wants to go after not only the whistleblower, but
the media outlets that publish the stuff as well,
the journalists as well, completely attacking
overtly journalism as an institution.
Speaker 3: To subvert our government
and our democracy. When possible,
we will press criminal charges. There you go.
As many as 100,000 government positions could
be moved out and I mean immediately of Washington
to places filled with patriots who love America.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So first of all, it's like, sure,
sure. You're going to do that right after your new
health care plan and Mexico is going to pay for it
as well. Right. So so of course, with all of these
things, it's less about what Trump will do, but
what Trump would like to do or is willing to admit
that he would try to do this would be endlessly
chilling, so corrosive to many of the fundamental
institutions of American democracy. And in a
sense, it's the same old song and dance. This
is the real grievance politics. When we've talked
before, the right says the left wants to censor.
It's the right that's doing a lot of censoring.
The right says the left is going to try to steal
an election. Well, the right tried to steal it,
steal the election. And of course, the right
loves to say the left is all about grievances,
grievances over racism and grievances over this,
that the other thing the right is running at
this point, the height, the epitome of grievance
politics. But it's based on grievances that are
imaginary, completely imaginary grievances. So
Trump looks to absolutely terrible. He sounds
terrible. He is now regularly releasing these
videos, often at midnight or even later. They
don't make any sense. They're scary. And if you're
wondering, like, why is Trump doing this stuff
when it seems like he's about to get arrested?
The New York Times article we talked about earlier
says that Trump's totally disconnected from the
reality of his legal problems. Trump seems to
think that it's all going to be great. He wants
to be handcuffed. He thinks it's going to be great
for his campaign and that he's going to win and
then it's going to put in place a truth commission
would be really scary if he were likely to be able
to do it. But it's up to us to make sure that
he's not able to. That clip I just played and
others from today. You can find them on our
Instagram. You can find them on our YouTube
channel. You'll be able to find them on our
TikTok or anywhere else that we publish content.